leute jetzt kommt wirklich die beste
szene ich bin zehn minuten gefahren oder
spaß und zeigt direkt geblitzt wurden
geil
trotzdem muss man natürlich ganz klar
sagen wenn ihr jetzt nicht immer meine
videos schauen würde dann könnte ich
über solche dinge im leben halt gar
nicht nachdenken so was musst du dir als
nächstes von auto und
das weiß es sehr zu schätzen
[Musik]
ist das sind schon weiter hey leute was
geht ab herzlich willkommen bei einem
neuen video organ und auch schönen guten
morgen wir haben gerade irgendwie 9 uhr
sa so für mich geht es jetzt nach
es ist ja ich bin echt schon richtig
spät dran deswegen würde ich sagen
erkläre ich euch den rest im auto auf
jeden fall fahren wir uns ein auto
anschauen ich weiß jetzt mitbekommen
habt letztlich kann man das video ich
kaufe das günstigste auto der welt das
hat 20 euro gekostet dass man heuer
jetzt fußball und hab ich mir gedacht so
als kleinen kontrast kann man ja auch
mal ein wirklich teures auto nehmen und
das passt auch wirklich gerade sehr gut
halt weil ja gut ich hatte jetzt ein
bisschen scheiße an ich muss das in ruhe
noch mal im auto erklären
bis gleich also vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz das ist ja mein jetziges auto
kennen ja auch wahrscheinlich die
meisten von euch mustern und wie das bei
youtube an so beliebt ist ehrlich zu
sein finde ich es immer so lustig wenn
sich darüber aufregen nach youtuber die
ganzen autos gefahren sind doch eh nur
geleast das ding ist die autos von
anderen unternehmen juba sind an sich
auch unternehmen wenn man es genau nimmt
also jedes unternehmen liest eigentlich
autos einfach weil es rechnerisch
anschlossen ist und ich meine das auto
bei mir zum beispiel geld als
firmenwagen kann ich jeden monat
absetzen und alle anderen alternativen
werden okay das habe ich jetzt schon mal
gesagt auch wenn es eigentlich gar nicht
zum thema passt wir fangen jetzt erst
mal los
es geht nach velbert hey leute und
schaut euch mal das wetter an
man sieht eigentlich so gut wie gar
nichts also irgendwie war im april das
wetter besser als in meiner scheiße war
mir auch weil ich das auslaufen erfahren
wollte wenn es regnet ist natürlich
nicht ganz und weiß was ich aber es doch
auf jeden fall sagen wollte was ich eben
nicht gesagt habe erstens meine haare
habe ich heute falsch gemacht also ja
ich habe den falschen wachs benutzt
deswegen wäre später aufgefallen
und zweitens den mustang ja ich sehe das
ganz junge was geht hier ab weiter
schaut mal
das muss man halt auch ganz klar sagen
muss sagen bei diesem wetter ist der
absolute horror für mich zumindest auf
jeden fall was jetzt noch ganz wichtig
zu sagen also den mustern
wenn ich jetzt gerade hab den habe ich
noch ungefähr bis 2020 also noch ein
bisschen und dann gebe ich ihnen ganz
normal wieder ab deswegen schaue ich
mich halt gerade schon
ich will nicht sagen dass ich mich
wirklich aktiv umschau aber man kriegt
natürlich hier und da mal was mit wer
welches auto fährt und ich habe auch
schon einiges über das auszusortieren
heute also anschauen werden ich schaue
da natürlich immer dass mir das auto
gefällt und das ist am ende auch einfach
nicht zu teuer wird obwohl ich da auch
so denke am ende ist es halt einfach
eine steuerfrage und man kann das
absetzen und es ist manchmal sogar gut
wenn es teuer ist ja deswegen fahren auf
die youtuber also könnte autos das ist
eigentlich gar nicht mal so und was mir
aber auch noch ganz wichtig ist also ich
mache mir jetzt eigentlich nur weil ich
ja letzten ist das günstigste auto
gekauft habe und wir uns dann jetzt mal
so als vergleich so
das teuerste auf jeden fall mit
anschauen ist halt auch von bmw und das
günstigste was gekauft haben waren auch
ein bmw deswegen passt das glaube ich
ganz gut
und trotzdem muss man natürlich ganz
klar sagen wenn ihr jetzt nicht immer
meine videos schauen würde dann könnte
ich über solche dinge im leben halt gar
nicht nachdenken so was wolltet ihr als
nächstes von auto und das weiß für ich
sehr zu schätzen und da kann man nicht
oft genug danke sagen ja ich bin mal
gespannt
wir sehen uns wenn ich angekommen bin so
leute ich bin jetzt bei bmw in vellberg
da steht auch schon ein geiles auto aber
den meine ich gar nicht also den schauen
und sollte nicht an ich muss erstmal
gucken wo ich hin muss und dann melde
ich mich also ich weiß schon kurz da hat
mir das auto schon einmal angeschaut und
ich würde jetzt sagen wir schauen uns
das jetzt mal zusammen an ich muss
wirklich sagen ich hab dir natürlich auf
videos schon gesehen und so wie in echt
alter also das wirklich ich weiß nicht
ich bin so voll leute ich muss aber auch
sagen ich würde mich das gar nicht so
viel davon beeinflussen lassen weil ich
habe mein auto halt noch eine weile
und wir machen wenn ich auf jeden fall
ob wieder ein cooles car porn aber nicht
hier
ich zeige euch schon einmal jetzt das
auto wie es aussieht von der seite
[Musik]
und das heftigste ist die türen gehen
halt irgendwie hier auf und dann gehen
hier so nach oben alter wir machen jetzt
nur eine kurze fahrt wir fahren uns
nämlich ein haus anschauen was ich im
internet gefunden hat da will ich noch
gar nicht zu viel von verraten ja also
ich bin bereit wir können durch war okay
brauche ich freue mich so ne ich war
jetzt muss das so die größte challenge
das ist ich weiß nicht das ist nochmal
viel also was ganz anderes als in meinem
auto und das ist auch das erste mal dass
ich jetzt schon so einen krassen
sportwagenfahrer reich sind deswegen ja
ich freue mich heute das krasse ist das
ist mein auto oder nähen ein hybridauto
und startet halt mit strom
man hört wirklich gar nichts das ist
schon ich würde auch selber noch nie ein
auto gefahren
deswegen
zimmer im sportmodus schon
hier ist kein sitzenbleiben
und dann alle auf fanatiker also ich bin
jetzt kein auto youtube-kanal deswegen
kann ich jetzt nicht alles wirklich
immer autos erzählen ich hoffe die drauf
trinken und denken hat jetzt ein paar
infos sowie 8
das auto
[Musik]
aber das heben wir nochmal das ist für
mich auch nochmal was ganz neues so und
keine ahnung also ich weiß gar nicht was
ich dazu sagen das macht auf jeden fall
spaß damit zu fahren und ich würde sagen
bevor wir jetzt hier weiter um labern
wir können ja einmal schon drehe ich mal
um immer leute und zwar genau dieses
haus ich weiß ich jetzt könnte sein dass
sich das zensiere
weil das habe ich im internet gefunden
und hier wohnt halt kein schwein und so
was könnte man halt eventuell mal in
anspruch nehmen für eine weitere folge
von das günstigste von das weiß ich aber
noch nicht vielleicht ist auch viel zu
teuer keine ahnung erstmal fahren wir
uns aber irgendwo hin wo ich ein cooles
video von auto man kann also angeboren
und ich würde sagen da würde ich euch
viel spaß mit
das machen wir jetzt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
mit
pfingsten geplant of the best
leute jetzt kommt wirklich die beste
szene ich bin zehn minuten gefahren oder
spaß und zeigt direkt geblitzt wurden
geil
das ist ein schönes erinnerungsfoto
[Musik]
also leute wieder zurück ich muss
wirklich sagen
ganz heftig also es hat richtig spaß
gemacht und ich habe mich darüber
gefreut dass sie nur ein mal probe
fahren konnte wie es jetzt weitergeht
müssen das gleich mal checken
so jetzt herausstellt probefahrt viel
spaß so leute ich bin jetzt ich finde
das so krass auf der kameramann sie
immer ich würde nicht sehen ich gerade
teil so selber und das sieht so aus als
hätte ich eine glatze weil meine haare
einfach überhaupt nicht sieht auf jeden
fall bin ich jetzt schon wieder zurück
in meinem auto
ich habe da nicht mal gefilmt ich habe
noch ein bisschen gequatscht und ich
habe mir natürlich ein angebot eingeholt
das ding ist das ist ja ein hybridauto
also der fährt bis zu einer gewissen
geschwindigkeit oder kann er nur mit
strom fahren und die werden halt sehr
gut subventioniert das heißt ich habe
ein richtig richtig gutes angebot
bekommen das wir eigentlich blöd wenn
ich das nicht machen würde
einfach weil es auch wirklich ein
richtig geiles auto ist da würde ich
mich selber glaube ich im nachhinein
ärgerlich sagt hey du hattest die
möglichkeit dieses zu holen
man soll es dann auch finde ich ruhig
mal machen deswegen da werdet ihr in
zukunft auf jeden fall noch irgendwas
von hören und ich war jetzt erst mal
nach hause und ich bin auf jeden fall es
war eine wirklich extrem coole fahrt und
ich bin sehr glücklich
leute was geht mir ist aufgefallen so
wirklich ein ende habe ich noch gar
nicht gefunden
deswegen muss ich das auch nachträglich
machen gerade hier noch das video zu
ende geschnitten wo ich gerade bin
seitdem nächsten video oder auf
instagram auf instagram heissig skikurs
alex wie ist auf jeden fall recht
angenehm warm
und ja ich wollte euch noch mal fragen
was hier so von der sache halte ich habe
das im instagram auch schon mal
angesprochen und das ding ist ich hatte
mein jetziges auto noch eine weile
und ich finde irgendwie im leben gibt es
auch andere probleme als über so etwas
nachzudenken trotzdem reist ist ein
natürlich und das angebot was davor
liegt ist wirklich unschlagbar
deswegen schlägt gerne mal eure meinung
in die kommentare
das war es von dem video ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen das soll jetzt nicht
irgendwie protzig oder sonstwie
rüberkommen ich habe einfach nur gedacht
komm mach euch ein blog zeige ich euch
mal was wir uns also anschauen ja und
ansonsten schöne grüße von hier und
demnächst wieder mehr haut rein